welcome to this video I'm playing hoax
here with black them making a conscious
effort to play something else not what i
usually do I need to stop this losing
streak and maybe try something entirely
different him benko gambit okay mmm can
I take on before I guess not but it's
not bad and this is like it would be no
knee here with them with the queenside
closed it shouldn't be shouldn't be bad
really I can even get in a quick at 5pm
let's do that
okay that's not bad
again even okay let's let's let's check
first I can just take it yeah and then
what is thought is best here I can also
take a DA be one and then aged to what
okay well this is really good enough
yeah that is good enough hg Queen takes
King d2 Queen f 2 wins the rook even and
if he goes to e2 how this looks totally
crazy I have a form amongst others check
how to do that before or yeah or maybe
just 97 and it's just just just develop
stuff I don't really want to trade
queens am NOT with such an uncoordinated
position on the other side ok I can give
the trick here first is this somewhat
something helpful check first maybe
maybe not yes not this is this is just
ok that's a pawn and in excellent
position radium I get this direct play
here against their three Pawn
that try to play quickly not allowing
anything crazy on the clock nidus trying
to go to g5 yeah now I manage then that
would put optimum pressure against their
phone they have work to deform in
addition entering White's camp
yeah it's not like he can move much but
I'm also not able to to strengthen it at
anyone how to really make progress here
maybe I still need to regroup this
summer get eg6 age 5 going night maybe
to a form maybe not to air form it could
be could be the way
now f's a half time yet I don't don't
need to rush things be here
now I don't want to exchange it um so go
back first here and only now if I could
96 this Bishop d3 coming it's not really
great get this in first no here and I to
have form yeah I can walk the King over
it's unbelievable that I need to apply
an endgame here after this opening but
okay at least i'm i'm glad that i think
i have total control IAM check
I'm trying to play Bishop f4 okay I'll
take it get the looks on the edge file
and rook h1 check made just activate
King to g5 and go from there check check
okay um how do you win this now maybe
just hear him with Luke a one coming
white resigns yeah is it took me some
moves after this opening yeah Queen edge
for check yeah Bishop e7 as much
stronger with bishop age for coming yeah
the main problem was that I had had a
hidden ahead of 10 G for after which I
need to drag queens this is for example
very strong now g4 is answered by this
okay now again after that time he gets
the Queen's off its it's a terrible
position but at least you can still
continue so I managed to get a winning
with the bank oh I should maybe continue
to play some stuff I don't usually play
okay thanks for watching